A bra gun holster?
An electromagnet plus balls equals
woooo!
Vsauce, Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Touch screens are okay,
but how about touching a force field?
Using infrared sensors this multi touch system
allows a traditional monitor to be
manipulated by hand. It can also be
suspended in air
to control a screen from afar.
Bosses can spy on their workers from afar
with this telepresence balloon.
This floating blimp shows a projection of
a person's face.
It's controlled remotely and broadcasts
audio through a built-in speaker.
If that wasn't weird enough, just hug a robot.
Telenoid is another telepresence device,
except it has facial expressions
transmitted from the user through webcam
and facial recognition software.
And don't worry, there's a handheld version.
Bipedal robots are usually heavy and unstable, but Kermit here can hop.
And that giant arm isn't being used to
aid in the jumping,
even though it looks like.
Humans can hop higher with the Bogo
Pogo, a redesigned pogo stick featuring a 'boassist,'
an aircraft grade aluminum.
Using audio-video illusion the McGurk effect
is a perceptual phenomena which
causes your vision to overmatch your
hearing.
The man says "bah," but your eyes see "fah,"
so you end up hearing "fah."
Now it's time for a giant cross
post slingshot.
This thing shoots 6 steel balls simultaneously to
to trash watermelon and wood boards.
To learn how to MacGyver things for
yourself
check out Mac recipes, a website
dedicated to every MacGyver-ism. And still
not sure how we turned that coffin
into a jet ski. I'm also not sure how this
helps you play basketball,
but apparently a French team seems to
think that it works.
Converse made a huge mirror out of Chuck Taylor's
that works by mapping the user's
movements and spinning the sneakers.
Breakfast is said to be the most
important meal of the day.
So, here it is floating in slow motion.
But you might prefer eating ten pounds
of gummy bears
that reenact your favorite classic video
games, like Breakout
and Pac-Man.
Finally, here's a real
epic animatronics from John Nolan.
I'm gonna leave you with the riddle.
There was green house.
Inside the green house
there was a white house.
Inside the white house
there was a red house.
Inside the red house
there were a lot of babies.
What is it?
And now for the genius of the week.
There are four video game references
in this video and there's one at
Facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
Find all five video game references
and leave your answer in the comments
below. The first person to do so
correctly
will be our genius of the week.
Good luck.
And as always,
thanks for watching.